we know what will happen to our
ukrainian brothers and sisters if they
lose the war to russia
lose the war lose your freedoms freedom
i believe is everything nothing
else
matters
that's why it troubles me tremendously
when people like
joy reid reduce the freedom struggle of
the ukrainians down to the lowest of
human values
race
[Music]
wow can you believe it i'm still here
living on this rooftop inside this tent
where i've been for over 100 days
bring to you the issues and awareness
that you need to know about the violence
on the south side of chicago and also
issues that impact our country and our
world
trying to raise as much money as
possible to build a community center on
this much needed block called o block
it's called o block because it's named
after a young man named od perry who was
shot and killed the gangs took the o in
his name and start calling it o block we
decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to change it to opportunity
block i'm so grateful and thankful to
fox for giving me a major
platform and a major opportunity to
bring to you every single day rooftop
revelations where i share with you my
thoughts viewpoints and opinions on
issues as it relates to chicago
america and the world
like many concerned americans i've been
following the war that
russia has launched upon ukraine
matter of fact it's pretty much all that
we've been talking about on this rooftop
on the south side of chicago
it's one of the reasons why i haven't
been able to bring to you rooftop
revelation the one thing that has been
so inspiring for us is to see how
bravely and strongly these ukrainians
are fighting for their freedoms the
freedoms that many of us in america take
for granted
we know what will happen to our
ukrainian brothers and sisters if they
lose the war to russia
lose the war lose your freedoms
freedom
i believe is everything nothing else
matters
that's why it troubles me tremendously
when people like joy reid reduce the
freedom struggle of the ukrainians down
to the lowest of human values
race
people like joy reed seem incapable of
seeing anything beyond the racial lens
it's all that she has race seems to be
her power
on her show joy reid recently accused us
americans of ignoring wars featuring
people of color like the yemen war in
favor of wars fought by whites and
christians she said and i quote the
coverage of ukraine has revealed a
pretty radical disparity in how human
ukrainians look and feel to western
media compared to their browner and
blacker counterparts
wow
does anyone seriously think that joy
reid
covered the yemen
war in the past
i mean it's been going on for years and
if joy reid has covered it then where is
the coverage i haven't seen it
if any
i i bet she didn't cover it any
serious way because she couldn't make it
about
race
just like so many others
race is her power her substance race is
a reductive force that bypasses human
complexities for the overly simplistic
values that we project unto skin colors
in asking us to ignore human
complexities race makes us liars out of
us and by imposing her views of race
onto the ukrainian russian war joy reid
attempted to make the war about herself
her views of race
and that
is worth what
that is why i've steadfastly refused to
play the race card
race is not my power
my intellect and my ability to
understand complex issues like the
ukrainian conflict that's my power
not race
there are some of you that may say what
about the africans being denied entry
into other nations
i condemn those acts of racism
at the same time
don't you know that the poland has taken
in over 100 different nationalities in
the last three weeks while racism may
have played a part we must also ask if
nationalism and citizenship issues
played a role as well
not just race
also i've read stories
of visitors to the ukraine describing
their experiences
one of the stories i came across was a
woman on twitter says she visited a
hotel several years ago and when the
clerk saw her armenian name she told the
guests that she was not welcome there
the hotel manager overheard it and fired
the clerk on the spot and told her never
come back
he then told the armenian woman that her
hotel stay had been comped
ukraine
like america
doesn't have the perfect past
what ukraine did to the jews during the
holocaust was simply horrific
but because i believe in the ability of
our citizenship and civilization to
evolve to progress to move beyond the
sins of the past i must give the
ukrainian people credit for evolving to
become a modern nation with modern
sensibilities they have fought for
freedom over and over since the end of
the cold war and today they are in the
fight to death
for what
freedom
those who do not move beyond the past
those who hold on to past grievances
those who do not rise to join the modern
world
those people have nothing to offer us
instead of building themselves into a
superpower nation russia invaded ukraine
in the name of a long gone empire
instead of doing her job and looking
into the complexities of the war joy
reid reduced the war down to race
because she had nothing else
to offer
[Music]
for joy reid
i believe attacking whites is her bread
and butter
she's absolutely nothing in reporting
without race
and now here
is the supreme irony of all this
joy reid blasted us for ignoring wars
involving brown and black people she
professes to care so much about brown
and black people
i then must ask
why hasn't she ever come into my
community to talk about the daunting
problems we deal with every single day
why hasn't she come here to learn for
herself how our plans for a community
center can transform so many lives
why hasn't she come here to share her
wisdom with us on the south side of
chicago
because she milks our pain for her
paycheck
she never visits us she never talks
about us so that is why joy reads
complain about the ukraine war ring so
hollow with me and that is why on the
south side of chicago i choose to fight
for opportunities for my brothers and
sisters instead of playing the
meaningless race game
that gets us
absolutely
nowhere
i know some are going to be bad some are
going to be upset
but i stand by what i say and what i
believe
and like i say
these are my viewpoints
my opinions
and today i brought to you another
rooftop revelation
and if god says the same until tomorrow
rooftop revelations
peace
you